THAT'S ALL. FOR JESUS.
AGAIN THERE'S NO JESUS SAID THAT AT ALL.
BUT THAT'S CHRISTIAN.
JESUS SAID JESUS SAID JESUS
JESUS. NO, I said Jesus. I SAID JESUS.
I SAID JESUS. NEVER BELIEVE THAT.
OKAY. OKAY.
I want to mention something.
No, no, no.
YOU GOT A PROBLEM.
WHAT DID THE BIBLE JESUS SAID THE ONLY
TRUE GOD IS THE FATHER. IS THAT TRUE OR
FALSE?
IS NOT
HE SAID WHERE JESUS SAID THE ONLY TRUE
GOD IS THE FATHER IS NOT TRUE.
GOD SENT TO WHOM YOU ARE SENT. AND JESUS
IS A PROPHET. That's it. That's it. So
wait, wait, let me finish. Let me
finish. No, let me finish. NOW, DO YOU
REMEMBER WHAT HE SAID? HE SAID NO, IT'S
NOT SOME OTHER TIME NOW.
He said JESUS IS THE POWER OF GOD. THEN
HE SAID JESUS CAME TOO LATE OUT LAY OUT
HIS LIFE. BUT JESUS IF HE CAME TOO LATE
OUT HIS LIFE, WHY WAS HE BEGGING ASKING
FOR HELP? COMPARE JESUS TO THE COMPANION
OF THE PROPHET MUHAMMAD. WHEN THE
COMPANION OF THE PROPHET Muhammad alaihi
salatu was salam, THE ARAB PAGANS TRIED
TO CRUCIFY HIM, DO YOU KNOW WHAT HE
SAID? Let me pray. AND HE WAS PROUD, NOT
SCARED TO DIE. JESUS IS GOD AND HE WAS
SCARED [screaming] AND BEGGING TO NOT
DIE. THIS PROPHET MUHAMMAD ALAIHI SALATU
WAS SALAM TO SHOW YOU you Jesus, not our
Jesus, you Jesus you believe our
respect, he was SCARED FOR HIS LIFE. HE
WAS WITH BIPOLAR. PROPHET MUHAMMAD
ALAIHI SALATU WAS SALAM WAS LAYING DOWN.
ARAB PAGAN came with a sword and tried
to scare him. He said, "WHO'S GOING TO
SAVE YOU?" PROPHET MUHAMMAD SAID,
"ALLAH."
AND WHAT HAPPENED? Allah saved HIM. HE
DIDN'T SAY, "PLEASE, DON'T KILL ME." SO
JESUS, OF COURSE, NO DOUBT. THAT'S WHAT
ALLAH SAVED HIM, NO DOUBT. SO ANYWAY,
ANYWAY, let me Sorry, it's my nature to
shout out. Sorry. NOW, WHAT I HAVE TO
SHOW YOU, IF YOU LISTEN TO HIM
CAREFULLY, PLEASE, I will highly
recommend the Christians out there be
honest and listen to his words. He keeps
contradicting himself. Jesus is the
power of God. Guess what? The power of
God got beat up. OKAY, NOW, HE HAD TWO
NATURE. I SAID TO HIM EXPLICITLY,
explicitly where Jesus said I am God and
a man at the same time. Nowhere. As for
John, in the beginning was the word.
And the word was with God.
So there's the word. The word Now, let
me finish. Let me finish. In the I know
it. I know the Bible better than you,
trust me. In the beginning I know better
than you, trust me. In the beginning was
the word.
And the word was with God. So there's
the word and there's God.
And the word is God. There's two Gods
here, yes? Okay?
Okay. In the beginning Shamsi.
And Shamsi is with Philip. AND SHAMSI IS
PHILIP.
HOW IS IT? THERE'S TWO PHILIPS NOW OR
SHAMSI OR THERE'S SHAMSI OR THERE'S
PHILIP? WHAT HAPPENED THE HOLY Spirit is
gone. The Holy Spirit is not there
anymore. My point here is that if he
says Jesus had two nature, there's no
where IN THE BIBLE. THIS BELIEF came
about after, okay? Even there's there's
different opinions when Nicaea Council
of Nicaea. What was the COUNCIL OF
NICAEA ABOUT? ABOUT JESUS' NATURE. So
the Christian [laughter] early
Christians never agreed on the nature of
Jesus. But where was it in the Bible?
Jesus said, "I'm going to my God and
your God." Does a God have a God? Does a
God have a God?
God have a God. Does a God have a God?
Answer. Does a God Does a God answer my
question? Does a God HAVE A GOD?
DOES IT OKAY. He just said God has a God
and he NEVER REFUTED HIM. THEREFORE,
LOGICALLY, there's no need to carry on
speaking with someone believe God have a
God. Come to Islam, take our Islam.